welcome back to another video today
we're going to be talking about anime
series dance in vampire bund a lot of
deaths have occurred recently and a
survivor claims the attacker is a
vampire on a game show five contestants
are asked if they believe in the
existence of vampires three of the
contestants say they don't believe it
and the other two think otherwise a
young girl is in the audience from
romania who enters the argument it's
then revealed by a mystery caller that
the girl who survived the vampire attack
was saved by one of her agents when
asked why her people got involved she
says that they were ordered by the
vampire princess a servant of the
princess by the name of vera is
introduced onto the show she then
reveals the arm of a vampire in a case
study suddenly one of the contestants
starts attacking people and it turns out
that the encased arm is his after biting
into a girl's neck he transforms into a
giant bipedal comedian he then escapes
from the show set to the roof there the
actual vampire princess is revealed to
be the young romanian girl she then
confronts the monster and kills him with
great ease the princess reveals her name
as mina she states that she'll be using
tokyo landfill number zero as the new
kingdom of the vampires and states that
it will be called the vampire bund
meanwhile student akira excuses himself
from class when the subject of vampires
was stirred up feeling uneasy about it
his classmate yuki catches up to him to
bring him a boxed lunch but she's soon
called in by student council president
nanami to discuss about the student
council financial report akira later
notices a girl who covertly observes him
when he touches her he instantly sees a
series of memories of her which causes
him a major headache the girl runs off
when yuki arrives later akira encounters
the girl in front of a billboard
introducing herself as mina the vampire
princess soon a military helicopter
fires missiles towards mina but agira
manages to cover her from the sudden
attack and they escape mina then asks
sakira to apply shade gel on her which
is to prevent her from deteriorating due
to the sunlight suddenly two assassins
disguised as police officers charged at
mina and akira yet they're still easily
defeated in the end on the top of a
large tower akira reveals that he has
amnesia due to a head injury he suffered
a while ago immediately after a spider
vampire attacks them when he flings
akira to the ground mina cries out his
name triggering a memory where he
promised to always protect mina when
they were younger akira rediscovers his
heritage as a werewolf of the earth clan
as he makes his way to the top of the
tower he slaughters the spider vampire
and rescues mina waking up in mina's
bedroom he realizes that last night's
happenings weren't a dream he's also
aware that some of his memories have
returned mina is now a transfer student
at arkire's academy however everyone's
shocked to see that mina and akira share
a master and servant relationship akira
receives a text message to meet up with
mina yuki manages to find him
questioning him about his association
with mina and the restoration of his
memories he tells her that it's
something his family decided for him to
be her servant the student council finds
out that mina is the actual founder and
chairwoman of the academy nanami wages
to capture akira and remove mina from
her position inviting all the students
to participate meanwhile mina and vira
are having a business meeting with
various political representatives
regarding the ratification of the
special zone establishment bill in their
presentation it's displayed that the
government has increased in debts and
decreased in bonds over time it's also
noted that the vampire corporation has
earned more income than the other
represented corporations
meanwhile the student council has akira
cornered a student meiren shoots hard
candy as a bullet into a window which
then distracts the student council and
allows akira to escape she leaves her
contact information on akira's cell
phone giving it back to him elsewhere
nanami is seen being engulfed by a horde
of zombie vampires mina is planning to
hold a worldwide press conference all
members are thoroughly tested to be
humans for security measures she's
greeted by a noble vampire who hates
akira and vera forcing both of them to
leave later they go on top of a large
tower where they converse about their
loyalty toward mina vera goes on to say
that the vampire race will cease to
exist if the death of the princess were
to occur meanwhile the noble vampire
reports that one of his newly recruited
agents has gone missing and a deadly
bomb has recently been stolen when mina
halter press conference akira and vera
try to search for the bomb akira and
vera find out that a reporter has the
scent of shade gel confirming she's a
vampire during the conference the
reporter attempts to attack mina akira
restrains her and vera stamps her in the
chest which incinerates her body the
bomb however has already been activated
unable to disarm it akira throws the
bomb into a disabled elevator shaft
causing a small explosion the students
of the academy still seem to be worried
that mina is a vampire princess and
akira is her servant the television
broadcast reports that the prime
minister is against the special zone
establishment bill and wants to dissolve
the assembly
one of the students shows akira photos
confirming the rumors about nanami being
attacked by vampires suspecting mina to
be the culprit later akira and yuki are
sadly ambushed by zombie vampires
surprisingly wearing the same school
uniform as them meanwhile mina goes to
see a politician trying to convince him
to back down from his opposition towards
the special zone establishment field but
she doesn't have any luck during a
downpour while akira is brutally beaten
by the zombie vampires mae ren steps in
at the last moment and takes on the band
with ease later it's revealed that mina
sent one of her servants to kidnap the
prime minister's grandson after he
refused to reason with mina
meiren confronts akira by explaining
that mina orchestrated the recent
attacks targeting her to persuade him to
be her only protector causing akira to
start doubting and distrusting mina he
then finds out that mina has the prime
minister's grandson in custody at the
academy a student tired of being bullied
is revealed to have vampire teeth marks
on his neck as he makes his way towards
yuki akira comes in the nick of time and
knocks out one of his fangs with his
elbow however the vampire runs away
before akira had the chance of learning
who had turned him into a vampire akira
confronts mina about the kidnapping of
the prime minister's grandson and the
infiltration of the vampires into the
school mina's responsible for only the
abduction a television broadcast informs
that the prime minister has announced
his early retirement in which the bill
may be passed after all akira later
gathers the student council inside a
chapel constructing a scheme to
eradicate the vampires from the school
akira leaves to bring back weapons for
the students as the student council is
confined inside the chapel for the night
they hear nanami's voice yuki's
distressed to see nanami turned into a
vampire on his way back to the chapel
with a stash of weapons akira is stopped
by alphonse the head of mina's sabotage
unit who says that he suggested the
kidnapping to have the bill passed
alphonse and akira's father explained
that all the attacks that have happened
so far were to lure out the conspirators
against the vampire society which is a
terrorist organization called telomere
meanwhile mina appears in the chapel
when nanami attempts to buy yuki mina's
disappointed that a vampire named jean
had turned many of the students into
vampires as well as had manipulated the
prime minister to dissolve the assembly
mina severs jean's arm when he
transformed but one of jean's
subordinates distracts mina when a
student vampire charges him with his
knife akira steps in and deflects the
attack he then tears out jean's heart
causing him to vanish vera arrives at
the chapel with troops to treat all the
victims mina and akira challenge each
other to a jewel to the death as they
both transform into their true forms as
the fight causes the chapper to crumble
into ruins akira sacrifices himself to
save mina from a falling crucifix akira
wounded but still alive promises to
serve and protect mina no matter the
circumstance
the special zone establishment bill is
finally passed and akira is knighted by
mina and takes his place amongst the
greatest warriors on the surface things
appeared to have calmed down at the
academy but amongst the students there
are deep physical and psychological
scars that still haven't healed
elsewhere vera saves a young boy from a
rogue vampire who self-destructs and
learns that he's searching for nanami
inside the vampire bond mina and akira
later find nanami and proceed to chase
after her stopping in a forest they're
introduced to hysterica who quickly
surrounds them with her vampire minions
nanami escapes after preventing mina
from attacking hysterica however veera
shows up and engages in a battle against
her with the two speaking of their past
the young boy sneaks away from yuki to
find nanami who is overwhelmed by her
feelings for him and pleading to mina
for her death hysterica suddenly bashes
the boy aside and takes nanami with her
mina akira and veera wonder what she's
planning to do to the humans it turns
out that special capsules are implanted
in hysterica's vampire army causing them
to self-destruct via cell phone signal
which may take place in the underground
subway stations mina and hysterica met
on top of a tall building to negotiate
hysterica is caught off guard when vera
sets off a detonator causing the
building to collapse while falling
hysterical loses hold of a cell phone
and mina tries to obtain it but fails to
do so once underground mina reveals that
the station is surrounded by aluminium
foil and signal cancellation devices to
prevent any large-scale suicide bombings
a desperate hysterical orders have
weakened nanami to head to the roof of
the building to initiate the cell phone
signal to proceed with the plan the boy
comes to stop nanami knowing her
obsessive feelings for him and stabs her
with a knife when hysterica tries to
kill nanami and the boy by breaking the
bridge above mina transforms and saves
the two from plunging to the ground
below hysterica then realizes that the
knife that was stabbed into nanami is
actually an extract of mina's blood
making her the new master nanami pierces
hysterica's chest with a knife and vera
ejects the special capsule into it
igniting hysterica though that army is
asked to work for mina the boy opts to
become a vampire to stay by nanami's
side
vera abruptly receives a call that three
ships are approaching the vampire bund
the three clans visit the vampire band
questioning mina's nobility status she
is forced to marry within her lineage to
produce an heir to the throne the
leaders of the three clans sent
assassins after akira putting his life
in grave peril the wager is whichever
assassin can successfully kill akira by
daybreak then their respective leader
will be chosen to be the future husband
mina's told the archana is from a
different lineage and lifespan making
him unsuitable to marry mina must
undergo an unpleasant purity inquiry won
the test to see if she can produce an
heir to the throne or not meanwhile
alphonse takes akira away from the
assassins and clarifies the situation
mina's dealing with akira sees him off
as he prepares to battle for his life
alphonse goes to mina to tell her that
akira is determined to defeat all the
assassins and that he wants her to stay
strong for him from this mina raises the
stakes of her wager with the leaders of
the three clans offering her life as
collateral if none of the assassins can
kill akira then mina is freed from their
bed akira is up against an assassin with
tentacled arms who queries if he had
seen the legacy of the true blood
lineage the werewolf puts his life in
jeopardy much to his inability to
transform currently mehren luckily
arrives and rescues him revealing her
true form in the process after giving
him a sedative via mouth to mouth maeren
confesses her love for akira saying that
they belong together the same assassin
reappears and throws akira along with
himself into a deep pit changing into
yuki's appearance the assassin asks him
about the true blood legacy again
cutting through his chest with her arm
rendering him momentarily unconscious
when he wakes up he sees mina's
appearance asking him a third time about
the true blood legacy and enraged akira
transforms into a werewolf and murders
the assassin in anguish akira is treated
in a facility beneath the vampire bund
established by the fangless vampires
akira finds out that he couldn't
transform before because mayren forced
him to swallow hard candy that prevents
transformation temporarily he also
realizes that maeren works for telemore
akira has recovered all his memories
including that of true blood legacy
alfons tells mena of the shocking secret
behind the true blood legacy as well
two princesses were found in an
underground castle years ago and only
one of them can carry on the true blood
lineage meanwhile akira is brutally
wounded by an attack from the ware cat
may ren however he doesn't give up and
he uses his last bit of strength to
defeat her mina wins the gamble and the
leaders of the three clans eventually
swear oath to mina soon after mina and
akira reunite in the estate and mina
later makes a pledge to stay by akira's
side forever until the very end
so this is it for today's video if you
liked the video give it a huge thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel for more
videos farewell till next time